oh yeah it's friday and i got three
games that are wallet-friendly and
GameSpot approved this week's got three
games you won't want to miss and you
don't have to because there's 0 monies
and ready to play + a giveaway cuz we
like you so much first up a game that'll
make you laugh make you cry and more
than likely make you super pissed off
that you ever started the damn thing
it's super crate box and it's super free
on PC and iOS you got to grab the crates
to crap you shoot all the dudes in this
wickedly hard platformer to each crepe
gives you a new weapon for a son of a my
personal favorite is the flamethrower
because it oh god big it's too difficult
and you're gonna want to pick it up on
steam as soon as possible so you can get
angry at it get this game also put the
skin next up the mario kart style
console game comes to ios4 Frizzle with
f1 race stars it's like power sliding a
WRX on a lebaron budget and it's
officially licensed by formula 1 for
anyone who cares about that stuff the
races are short and sweet and the
controls are tighter than gelson's jeans
racecar drivers need energy to live and
you might find yourself spending real
dough to keep them racing but the game
will reward you as you play so you don't
have to give them all the cash if you
don't want it available this week just
watch out for those homing bubbles and
finally get out your wizard wands for
the spell spamming magica wizard wars
this dynamic real-time pvp game pushes
you to create magical elements on the
fly to create hundreds of spell combos
and make all the other wizards wet their
rows the rounds are quick and dirty the
action is fast and fun and the Wizards
are funny as hell and gamespot throwing
you keys that give you the closed alpha
a full retail value of 12 99 just going
to games.com / wizard wars giveaway and
before I forget gamespot is also doing a
watchdogs giveaway we're giving away a
ps4 limited edition box that have
watchdogs just enter on gamespot com
we're giving it away next Friday well
there you go three addictive games
miam price of absolutely nothing see you
next week play on